[Music]
in harsh punishment news submitted by
plotholes a young man went through a
whirlwind with a judge after
accidentally missing jury duty literal
whirlwind or so this guy he's 21 years
old from Florida his name is DeAndre he
was selected as a juror for a civil
automobile accident negligence case and
he was supposed to have come back the
next day at 9 a.m.
was that me I usually record neutral and
just roll down the street and smash to
somebody
automobile accident negligence case it's
a they're suing for money because
someone was negligent with their
automobile yeah you put it in neutral at
the car volts well somewhere it could be
that was very civil could be that so he
was supposed to show up at 9:00 he
overslept woke up at 11:00 he was like
oh dang is past the time Sky's a gamer
for sure so instead of going to or
instead of calling the bailiff or going
into the courthouse once you woke up he
ended up going to the doctor noon job
where he works at an after-school
program at this Rec Department saving
the rector's you know small town where's
that Florida Beach Florida
that's big big big like a big city Wow
so um he also lives with his
grandparents so he like his grandparents
are are dependent on him to like take
him to two appointments and stuff so
anyway take him to his Wow tournaments
the grandpa know the kid that'd be funny
though if there's a whole family is the
Kame where's me all right
yeah so then he thought like oh maybe
I'll just get a fine or something like
sorry nobody you go to jail so he ends
up showing up oh because they they end
up showing up at his house oh then he
had to go to court and once he showed up
the judge convicted him of direct
criminal contempt because he did admit
to not like to just deliberately going
to work instead of like trying to
contact the courthouse so he got a
10-day
they'll sentence as well as 12 months
probation 150 hours of community service
and in order to write an apology letter
so that was all because he he overslept
a mystery I'm gonna go to jail for 10
days cuz then you get this street cred
and the stories with that had been over
too long I want I want to be I want to
know what what would he actually did
that MIT we don't even do anything
he put his car in neutral no no he it
wasn't even him he was the one who was
gonna be the jury wasn't even him he got
picked as a jerk oh oh like he didn't
even do the crime yeah he did it so the
ground was she got in trouble because
she turned off the alarm clock for him
to miss the time but yes so he ended up
getting that and also 233 dollars in
fees so Oh thinking really harsh you get
the most serious judge I've ever heard
yeah I couldn't make it jerk to jury
duty and I called and I was like yo I
can't do this [ __ ] and they're like oh
don't worry can you do it tomorrow and I
was like you got selected to beYOU jury
once he got selected that's like being a
part of that Steven Avery case he did
it's like today I overslept I don't want
to go oh and also this by him doing that
and not showing up it delayed the the
entire trial 45 minutes yeah so the
judge wanted to make an example and I
pretty much make it clear to everyone
like how important it is that you show
up once you're picked that's why you
don't get picked bow so he ended up
reducing his his probation from a year
to three months and also said that if he
shows up how did he have a like that oh
because like oh because then DeAndre I
ended up like appealing it and doing a
really tearful like apology after
spending those ten days in jail what a
great performance I think he was sorry I
really think he was he just seemed
really like it was an image module what
if they sent me to jail Oh apologize to
him yeah for him I'm sorry that was
uncalled for
I highly uh regret my words you know
this channel is is is about serious yeah
do what he did cheek stinks nah that's
cool I brushed my teeth
good this is a serious channel we should
change our name to serious news oh just
serious news you just said serious and I
wasn't sure what you're gonna say next
then he surprised me the news I think
you couldn't just serious news serious
kidding you seriously kidding news oh
that's pretty good
but yeah so that's how he was able to
reduce it and so the judge also said
that he had to go in once a week and
talk to do a 10-minute presentation to
jurors to tell it talk to them about the
importance of jury duty oh he's like I
had a [ __ ] of a time when I mess up like
that so then instead of however many
hours I said before it will be 30 hours
of community service and each 10-minute
talk would count as three hours I don't
know if getting missing jury duty and
getting your [ __ ] stretched is a fair
exchange you know what I mean no no sir
is he I'm like PTSD for missing the
alarm now just exponentially one
careless I wish I could but a photo of
him oh I could be that careless robbed
like on his jury like oh man this guy
looks so innocent like he doesn't know
what the hell just happened to him dick
look look at his face he looks like he
got caught doing like really like no no
the the boy like he's in mid like
disbelief like [ __ ] you hadn't do [ __ ]
he's there no the only thing I did wrong
was lose my man game at 3 in the morning
yeah I don't you wish I mean I wish I
had that level of carelessness where I'm
just like ah [ __ ] it but you know what I
do care about is the fans subscribing so
make sure y'all subscribe because I
don't want y'all to go to jail if you
stay subscribe to JK news what will end
up happening
you'll learn all these things like don't
miss when you become a juror do not miss
or else you're gonna get your ass holes
displayed and replace it does it say how
deep his ass hole was splitting or
replaced yeah okay it's probably it's
probably been stretched very far and I
don't think the punishment fits the
crime because here the only crime was
being a young man sleeping in know yeah
but you guys ever been it's like for
jury duty I thought you're gonna say
have you guys ever had your [ __ ]
stretch yeah but that - that's the main
question no to both
I've been this close this [ __ ] close
no no maybe this close like I know some
ass play I wasn't sure how deep no dad
say oh maybe one I'm 5050 after you're
getting your prostate checked in sa'
yeah and then my [ __ ] might be more
loose but right now it's too scared but
anyways what ended up happening was okay
you wait the whole [ __ ] day right and
then they get you get chosen to like
these different courtrooms or whatever
and then they grab like a group of like
30 or 40 people the first 12 go up and
then everyone else is on the bench I
mean on the side like it's a [ __ ]
Judge Judy show or like you're in the
audience right and then they start
interviewing them and then you see like
the different [ __ ] sides saying yeah
we want him no we don't want them and
then they start pulling and then when
people get dismissed like new people
come in and thank god they locked it in
before I got it yeah and I was like if I
was preparing what to say to I was like
man you know I'm gonna say I'm gonna
stay like I believe the devil is my Lord
and Savior I believe that Hitler is a
strong God I believe like I don't know I
was gonna say some crazy [ __ ] and
hopefully they won't pick me because it
was a case about a the dude shot a cop
or something like that
and then they were asking the people in
the juror if they had like family
members that were police officers or
that or they're looking for biases yeah
dude I was almost selected for jury duty
around the same time as the Michael
Jackson trial and so I was like you hope
all [ __ ]
Hoboken's Michael Jackson trial because
it's like forever and it's a bunch of
media attention I would want to yeah but
I think he's guilty I would know [ __ ]
you Stevie pal let's go there I think
he's [ __ ] guilty I just watch I just
watched return to Neverland or whatever
or leaving Neverland I think that
[ __ ] guilty did you watch part
1 & 2 I watched both of that [ __ ] what
do you think I I don't wanted that just
came out right the most recent it wasn't
the one that came out like fairly recent
like last a pollution [ __ ] okay let me
ask you a question yeah just because
someone told you that they had to spread
their ass cheeks while somebody beat off
and then you stared back at them just
because someone told you that would you
believe that but what have multiple
people said that and they were all
independent of each other I mean all had
similar accounts of what Michael Jackson
damn y'all sound like lawyer but I
thought only a few people said that and
everyone else me too no it's only three
I was like you you say you didn't want
to be on the skids it sounds like you
want to be on this case it's only three
they're all friends now I want to be
people that are in desperate need of
money that I have the same story that's
always the story though is that
everybody going after Michael wants
Michael's money but they all have
similar accounts of how he groomed them
to be down because it all came from the
first book yeah and then they all just
convened and they're like hey you don't
think that Michael Jackson was weird
with kids I thought he was like he slept
in the same bed with kids for [ __ ] a
decade no no no he slept and they slept
on his bed he slept on the floor
they date he said he even said he have
admitted to sleeping the same bit
escaped oh yeah he did many thought that
[ __ ] for sure okay but check this out
his bedroom is like three stories high
and there were other people in the room
too I don't know like the whole house
was a bedroom what about all the people
that made is a lying sack of [ __ ]
because because okay she's already been
caught for frosh she's already been
caught for being paid off right she's
already been she was guilty of other
crimes I'll tell you dis minimis she got
paid off to lie pindy caught both of
that that's why she's discredited by
music labels that were against Michael
and they wanted to take his rights so
anyway oh by the way check out square
one my friend directed and it's been
released and it's the whole rebuttal on
the 1997 case and with the [ __ ]
recent leaving nether Neverland and
everything like that it's it's it's out
now you can check it out square one
check it out I'd like to say check out
beat it which is a great song wait but I
wanted to tell you guys about DeAndre oh
yeah because there's like the last bit
of it oh it's a kind of a happy ending I
think so the judge says that he now
believes that the that DeAndre has been
totally rehabilitated and he ordered so
he said that he ordered the probation
because he wanted other people to
understand that serving on a jury is
serious business deserving of attention
respect and adherence to their oaths he
said that the publicity surrounding this
case made that clear so his punishment
is no longer necessary
and he will have a clean record oh god
yeah poor kid unlike Michael Jackson who
has eight berries not in clean record
[Music]
[Music]